well welcome everybody I hope you had a
great weekend it was an insane weekend
of political happenings and news and
events and I want to start with two
examples of anti-woke backfires now
later in the program we'll get back into
the perversion of the term woke we don't
have to do that here but we're first
going to talk about one of these
anti-woke book bans completely and
totally backfiring I told you weeks ago
that in Utah there was already an
attempt made to ban the Bible from
public school libraries
specifically because of the rule that
right Wingers put in place about violent
and sexual content in books and indeed
that has now succeeded in some schools
NPR reports a Utah school district has
removed the Bible from the school from
some schools shelves frustrated with
book challenges and bands in their
school district a parent in Utah
submitted a complaint of their own about
the Bible
now good for the Davis School District
they took the objection objection
seriously they placed the Bible under
review and the district officially
decided to remove the religious text
from elementary and middle school
libraries for containing vulgarity or
violence the ban takes effect
immediately with Bibles being removed
from classrooms even as they close down
for the summer Additionally the Book of
Mormon is now under review as a result
of the exact same thing so let's talk
about what's going on here the Utah book
ban by right Wingers is a case of
censorship backfiring the ban was hoping
to block
the normal The Usual Suspects right
books on lgbtq plus topics or by certain
authors of a particular identity racial
issues
ETC but what it has led to because of
how it is written violent content sexual
content the Bible is filled with violent
and sexual content it has led to the
Bible being removed for violence and sex
this shows a number of different
important characteristics of this
movement that we are now seeing number
one their hypocrisy because all of the
right Wingers who said we like the rule
opposed the removal of the Bible and
we've confronted some of them on the
show and they call in ETC and we say
well hold on a second if these are the
rules if this is the standard if this is
the barometer the checklist violent
content sexual content here it is in the
Bible here's examples of violence in the
Bible here's examples of sexual content
in the Bible on it so many of them they
say well that's different
well okay in what way is it different
they can't really articulate any
difference other than they don't want
the Bible removed the ban is also part
of this lar so it's arbitrary it's
capricious it's hypocritical the ban is
also part really of a larger trend from
the right of censorship while claiming
the other side is doing the censoring
and then using lawmakers and government
to achieve that very censorship of which
they accuse the other side I am against
book bands for a number of different
reasons number one they are taking
teachers out of the decisions as to what
materials are appropriate for children
of what age and putting it in the hands
of parents parents whose expertise is
not education whose expertise is not
literature whose expertise is not a
child development
so we're saying let's give people who
are less qualified the ability to decide
what is in school libraries they silence
authors
they silence Librarians they they damage
the trust and the dialogue between
schools and communities and also they
can have the very corrosive effect of
tying schools up not only in protests
but in legal challenges that's not good
for anybody that's not good for learning
as a progressive right I'm a progressive
I'm not for censorship
I I have to pause there I know the right
says we are the ones wanting to censor
no no no no I'm a progressive I believe
in the power of books to educate Empower
and empathize I believe in the power of
reading to develop vocabulary language
knowledge
Etc I want to let teachers decide
what's appropriate at which age maintain
separation of church and state meaning
the Bible gets no special status
and when it comes to teaching religious
texts I'm not against teaching religious
texts but they shouldn't be in science
class they should be taught as religious
texts maybe in comparative comparative
religion class or something like that
probably not to second graders would be
my sense in a public school so I oppose
book bands and I oppose the book bands
based on uh ideology and morality and
Common Sense and all these other things
I'm glad to have a dialogue I'm glad to
collaborate with teachers to determine
what are the appropriate texts at
different ages we might say you know I I
remember
I think it was second grade when our
teacher would read Roll of Thunder Hear
My Cry a book that in its unabridged
version contains the n-word it contains
violence about slavery Etc was it
inappropriate for second graders I don't
think so I remember being riveted
horrified to learn about the treatment
of slaves and the legacy of slavery and
all these things could you come out and
say you know that's probably really
better for like third graders or fourth
graders sure I mean listen these are
reasonable discussions saying we're
going to ban the book no I don't think
so so I stand with the anti-censorship
groups the student groups the teacher
groups Etc they are a threat and now
what we are seeing is this backfire on
themselves in Utah as the Bible has been
banned in some places The Book of Mormon
is now on The Chopping Block this is the
monster they created they have no one to
blame but themselves